hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
match first in like a lamb
out like a lion
and like a lion out like a lamb i don't
[ __ ] know i live out on the west
coast
i don't i don't even know what i don't
you guys need to report
to me i know you had a bunch of snow i
have no idea what the [ __ ] going on
this is what i do know i'm for three
i've been watching i got the celtics on
in the background recording this sunday
afternoon
75 71 minute 14 to go in the third
quarter
celtics need to win this game to go
seven and nine for the month
you know snapped a three-game losing
streak on friday night beating the
indiana pacers well you know
secretly one of my favorite [ __ ]
teams out there
simply because they're the only team i
ever saw
other than the boston bruins go into the
stand and
beat the [ __ ] out of people you know now
granted they didn't get the right people
but like
you know i think that that needs to
happen once a decade
once a decade a hockey team a basketball
team
you know baseball players remember that
time those two [ __ ]
dirt bags attacked that first base ref
ref
first base uh coach that was a while ago
and all the baseball players beat the
[ __ ] out of him it's just it it has to
happen
every once in a while because look at
people's behavior now
people blaming trump people blaming
hillary people blaming [ __ ] doctors
and all that's
you know everybody's got a [ __ ]
theory
you know and i think it's no coincidence
that when you look back over the last 10
years
no professional athletes went into the
stands and beat the [ __ ] out of regular
people i think it it needs to happen
sorry i got to be honest with you these
[ __ ] goddamn
tvs now every month and a half i need to
i have to relearn because there's some
sort of
update i i need to relearn how to turn
on my [ __ ] tv
to get regular tv and it's getting
harder and harder
to get regular tv because it just sends
you
there's this [ __ ] thing like i like
this new app and i'm like is it said tv
plus
i'm like is that t it says tv is that
what it is
is that what i hit and then i get on
right couldn't find that then i found
some search thing so i'm like all right
get me back to regular tv
i don't want to stream the 8 000 new
shows that came out in the last five
[ __ ] minutes
i don't care oh my god have you seen
none [ __ ] have you seen that one yet oh
it's a [ __ ]
female empowerment thing about a nun he
who rapes a priest oh
[ __ ] dude you gotta see it i don't
i don't i only have so many [ __ ]
hours in my day and i waste them
watching sports
that's what i want to do and i don't
want to watch it on a [ __ ] app
i swear to god if they would come back
with those big wooden [ __ ] tvs that
weighed 9 000 [ __ ] pounds
and you just went up and you just pulled
the knob i would i would be happy
you know not saying i don't love a
remote okay the remote was a great
[ __ ] idea
without a doubt but somewhere along the
line like i'm trying to turn my tv on
i'm sitting there
with [ __ ] two remotes in my hand like
i'm in a [ __ ] spaghetti western like
holding a couple of pistols trying to
figure this [ __ ] thing out and i
gotta hit the
press on the house on one of them and
then i gotta go
guide on the other trying to get that
[ __ ] thing to scroll
for two oh [ __ ] wrong team
yeah i mean a little [ __ ] everybody by
the way why are they wearing
why are the washington wizards dressed
like like a [ __ ] american airlines
plane
i literally thought that was us because
a couple nights ago i was watching the
celtics and we were wearing that same
gray
with green
oh god is this what getting old is like
you just start yelling at your tv
everything's changing too fast
i bet back in the day right it probably
freaked old people out when all of a
sudden tv was on
all day you know howdy duty used to come
on at four
and it was done everything was done at
night
jack parr said i'll [ __ ] see you
later
and then they play patriotic music
um anyway
[ __ ] yeah so you wouldn't know it i just
went on a vacation
and had a great time and three days of
rest and relaxation
as much as you can with kids and [ __ ]
but uh i had an awesome time
and everything was great i [ __ ] came
home i unpacked everything i mean
[ __ ] everything right and then i come
in here
and all i want to do all i want to do
is watch the celtics right that's all i
want to do just put it on the [ __ ]
background i just want to [ __ ] sit
down and i literally sat over there
like you know when it won't
when it doesn't do what i wanted to do i
yell at it
you know i was just sitting there with
the two remotes going regular tv
regular [ __ ] t i just want regular tv
i did that for like [ __ ] 11 minutes
trying to find this
[ __ ] stupid game
jeez i like i don't understand how much
time these flat screen tvs think i have
in a day
this [ __ ] thing has netflix amazon
prime
about 5 000 other [ __ ] things i've
never even heard of
and then like when i typed in abc just
to to get back
to the motherland regular tv
they had their own streaming thing it
was [ __ ] hilarious it came up
and all these stupid pictures of smiling
families you know
you know the the show picture
we've all been there we've all see every
every [ __ ] show right they had the
friends they were in the fountain
you know uh cheers they were sitting
around the bar hey bill how about a show
that didn't come out 30 [ __ ] years
ago all right um
uh
oh wait a minute i guess i don't want
tv no according to jim was a while ago
no there was one i watched i know i
watched it because i sat down
i said i was gonna watch it i can't
remember the name of it
oh [ __ ] i give up there's too much [ __ ]
i'm too [ __ ] old that's all
that's all i'm trying to say people
enjoy your youth enjoy your youth while
you can because you can end up like me
one day
and you poor bastards you're probably
gonna be holding four remote controls
screaming you know where is netflix
you know i don't want to you know china
will probably have like the number one
streaming [ __ ]
service at that point they finally take
over
right and everybody's watching that [ __ ]
everybody's [ __ ] speaking mandarin
and you're gonna be like ah speak
english and [ __ ] watch netflix like
we're used to
um so anyway we went on on a griswold
family trip
rented a big ass chevy suburban
i'm a ford guy driving the bow tie this
weekend
williams from pritchard
sorry um
anyway i uh ran into this big [ __ ]
um the [ __ ] was it a giant suburban
and we loaded this [ __ ] thing up i
brought my daughter's balance bike
i brought a scooter right we had all our
clothes and all of that [ __ ] and you
know
i was meeting some family out there out
in joshua tree
is where we went my wife always wanted
to go there so everybody got [ __ ]
tested
like the night before stayed away got in
our [ __ ] cars and then just
drove there and we like rented a house
and uh you know went into joshua tree
and all that
just had a [ __ ] great time and no i
did not say
where is the joshua tree although i will
tell you because
i don't know if you're new to my podcast
that's what i did the first time i
and only time i went there like 11
[ __ ] years ago
i uh i asked a park ranger where is the
joshua tree
you know because i thought it was a
specific one then i didn't realize it
was a speech species i thought it was
like some biblical [ __ ]
like job joshua one of those jay guys
jesus
right there's always some [ __ ] guy
with the first name begins with the j
in the bible telling you what to do um
so i said yeah that's what i said i said
where is where is the joshua tree no
in my defense if it's just a species
of tree is it species or we just call it
a strain i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm not into plants um
why why wouldn't you call it joshua
trees right not trying to be a douche
but
if every [ __ ] three days i can get a
text from some stupid
yellow tooth [ __ ] and great britain
going what do you call it football
uh like that like like they're the most
clever [ __ ] person like
nobody has ever said that you know
you know what this should be a [ __ ]
taser
everybody has a taser and legally you
are allowed to bring it out
when somebody says something says a
[ __ ] old joke
or or just oh i got ideas this week okay
here's one
here's one for you you know the one i
can't [ __ ] stand as i watch a lot of
these videos where people try [ __ ] and
then they [ __ ] up the fail videos
and there's always some douche has to
write
play stupid games win stupid prizes
and then people respond to it like it's
the first time they've heard it
that [ __ ] comment is under every
[ __ ] video you could literally
have an old lady reaching down to grab
her slipper and throw on her back
and some douche is gonna write play
stupid games win stupid prizes
it's not even a good [ __ ] saying
that's what pisses me off
that's what really annoys me you know
what i mean i get like uh hey you know a
broken clock is right twice a [ __ ]
day
you know i get that that makes sense
kind of clever
play stupid days with the stupid prices
like what i love is i just love
how hey look at [ __ ] dude put your
mask on put your [ __ ] mask on
i love people when they yell yelling
through a mask like it's it's not like
you're in a [ __ ] you know
a soundproof studio it's a [ __ ] paper
mache mask
for god's sakes by the way if somebody
[ __ ] sent me something saying you
know i want you to debate
with an expert somebody who who thinks
you shouldn't wear a mask it's like why
would i do that
i'm not an expert i listen to experts
doctors and nurses who work in hospitals
with covid patients who wear masks
and don't get it
and anytime i get tested by a nurse i
always i just feel the water
can you believe it and they just have
this this dumbfounded look on their face
and they just go just wear a mask i
don't i don't get why
they're not wearing a mask i'll tell you
why i'll tell you why
because there's too many [ __ ] options
for information
okay and we're all spread out back in
the day when you just turned your
[ __ ] tv on
and we all had this three same channels
the lies we could all get on the same
[ __ ] page
right back in the day sports were
awesome and you can't trust the russians
we were all on the same [ __ ] page
okay you could make movies about that
[ __ ]
you know red dawn the day after all of
this [ __ ] and it all [ __ ] made
sense to us because the average
dumb [ __ ] wasn't allowed
to chime in but now
everybody has a say do you realize if a
[ __ ] plane crashed
in the snowy [ __ ] wherever the alps
when they went to get out and if you
were lucky enough to have an army ranger
or a navy seal some special force guy
out there
who was going to tell you how to get the
[ __ ] out of there
there would be at least a third of the
passengers
okay would be looking at their
smartphones questioning
what the [ __ ] this guy had to say you
know not according to my research
some [ __ ] guy who can't even put up a
tent
he's gonna question some guy you know
i i don't know i give up so all you guys
ask me do it i am not an
expert but i i am smart enough to know
that i don't have a medical degree so i
listened to doctors and nurses during a
pandemic
jesus christ
like the people who say that like when
you're when your [ __ ] sink is busted
and you have a plumber come over what
are you
you're sitting there on your phone going
you know oh you need a new [ __ ] j
pipe thing whatever the [ __ ] it is the
sink traps fall is that you know
according to my research
and i could be a plumber too.net you're
gonna question that guy
why am i listening to him what just
cause he learned to trade he's all
greasy and has half his [ __ ] butt
crack hanging out
why do i know he's not part of the the
male toxic
patriarchy um anyway
clown ahead so we go out to uh wait
stupid game play stupid games win stupid
prizes
oh
anyways calm down bill all right
what i'm doing is i'm just trying to
energy my way through this [ __ ]
podcast because i was just driving
back and um i was a
for the most part i was a model citizen
this weekend
right i made sure that you know
i didn't bring up politics i didn't
bring up mass
i didn't [ __ ] you know i do it on this
[ __ ] thing it keeps you [ __ ]
console
at the edge of your seat getting all
[ __ ] mad you know spraining your
[ __ ] thumbs as you [ __ ] write
something to me that i'm probably not
gonna read
but you know makes you feel good um
anyway so i was told not to do any of
that [ __ ]
to basically not be
who i am you guys how [ __ ] funny that
is even though i know she's right but
can you imagine a [ __ ] world
where you could say yeah listen honey
you know there's gonna be a lot of
people out there just
no real housewives okay you know all
itch well that's not that's not fair
because real housewives is just real
housewives
i'm trying to think of something
annoying she does i would tell you guys
but you [ __ ] [ __ ] would tweet it
at her because you're a bunch of rats
um
all right plowing ahead so we [ __ ]
load up and i had the best time driving
out there
with the kids my lovely wife and all
that
you know we get out to the house and
everything
chill it out they could actually see the
stars it was so
quiet out there it was amazing there was
all these mom-and-pop places and [ __ ]
that i would have gone to
had it not been uh you know
all this [ __ ] going on we did stop
at one point because we needed some
snacks and we pulled into this one place
and jesus
christ the [ __ ] humanity in that
place it's just
it's just a [ __ ] shame all the money
that is spent
that you just don't have like one
standard [ __ ] level of education
out there you know
it's just it's so [ __ ] up it depends
on where you live
what books you get you know
how good the teachers are these poor
[ __ ] people you went in there and you
just
none of they didn't have a chance they
live out in the middle of the desert
right i'll always call to the the desert
it's my little [ __ ] thing
remembering greg giraldo it's kind of
hard to [ __ ] something
with your balls sticking to your leg out
here in the desert
um yeah
[ __ ] hard hard lives were lived
in that place you know some woman came
in looking all [ __ ] methy
and we had our masks on so she pulled
her shirt up god bless her and then in
the end she was standing in line behind
us with booze and she was
just covering her mouth and her nose
with her hand
there was some other guy over in the
corner just
really coughing and i'm looking at my
wife uh and she's like do you want to
get some pringles i'm like
neil let's get the [ __ ] out of here all
right
i don't know what that guy is coughing
up but he is coughing his [ __ ] brains
out
i let's get out of here so we got out of
there
and um anyways the rest was all good the
rest was all good but i don't like
seeing that [ __ ] you know the guy behind
the counter like his
his whole face looked like a gin blossom
it was so [ __ ] red and then his hands
were as white as mine i was like oh my
god
[ __ ] people addiction and all of this
[ __ ] going on out here i don't i don't
get it i don't get it then we go around
the world trying to [ __ ] oh we're gonna
try to fix this country
slash take all their natural resources
um
so anyway we go out there and uh
i had a great [ __ ] time um
my daughter learned how to whistle i've
been trying to teach it's funny when you
teach a kid how to whistle
you know they they make the noise with
with their voice
they go like it's like no no it's just
wind so she just kept doing it
and doing it into it and then all of a
sudden she got it and she was so friggin
proud of herself
and uh so now she can do it but she
can't do it every time it takes her like
10 tries
so she starts laughing and then she
can't get it so she smile and then she
goes okay wait a minute wait a minute
she's got to like
put her hand over her mouth and kind of
okay here we go
and then she gets it she's so friggin
excited it was awesome man
um so we drove back this morning
you know it was great i hadn't seen you
know
family members i was with i had not seen
them and
since all this [ __ ] started and uh
so it was awesome to see him
and uh so this morning we left
around midday i was thinking maybe we
were going to get stuck in some traffic
going back to la usually around the 15
you catch that vegas traffic but then
i'm thinking like
you know what there's no nothing really
open open in vegas as far as i know
so maybe we'll get lucky and we get on
the highway and bump
but just [ __ ] wall-to-wall people
like we were literally stopping which
never really happens out in l.a
as bad as the traffic is at least you
creep along i mean you'll have like
moments you stop for a second we were
stopping for like 30 seconds and i was
like this is a [ __ ] accident
so finally we got past it and i saw the
tow trucks cleaning up and you know
the car and throwing some [ __ ]
plastic bumpers to the side of the road
and i was joking with nia going like
you know you should have to write an
apology
to everybody that you made sit in
traffic
when you caused this level of a traffic
jam provided you know
if it wasn't just like literally an
accident but if you like looking at your
phone
and then you just spun out or hit
somebody or whatever they should make
you part of that
going out there cleaning it up they
should make you write a [ __ ]
write a [ __ ] letter it wouldn't deter
anybody but it'd be funny
so um the only bad thing that happened
when i was out there in joshua tree was
i was driving along the road and i was
and i was trying to find the house you
know they're all kind of spread out and
everything and i slowed down
and i i saw our house that we were
renting and i went to pull
in and this guy in the car behind me
this truck this great truck
he had like a speaker you know he could
have a cb or something and yell at
people
and i was sitting there and he just goes
get the [ __ ] off of my road
so uh yeah i don't know what this guy's
deal was
the thing that we rented had like
colorado plates on it and [ __ ] so i
don't know if that's what it was but
i don't know if he was [ __ ] around or
not
um i beeped at him to see if he'd stop
like what the [ __ ] was i gonna do i
don't know
just natural um
being a comedian feeling like you're
getting heckled or something but
afterwards like for the rest of the day
it was just making me laugh
um it was funny if he was just [ __ ]
around but it was even funnier if he was
serious
and like i can't tell you how many times
i've wanted to like have somebody
hear my complaint maybe i was going too
slow
any that happens a lot maybe they they
rent out a lot of those houses and this
poor bastard always has to slow down
because some [ __ ] like me he's like
looking for the house
if that's what it is it's actually
[ __ ] funny but um
you know if you like roll down the
window
to yell at somebody in your car that
gives them the opportunity to yell back
at you and what i love about what this
guy had was
i hadn't i he told me exactly
how he was thinking and there was
nothing i could say he couldn't hear me
so the guy totally wins it's actually a
great road rage
sort of device for people you know
they get to say it and then other people
don't have road rage or just be like
yeah you know
it doesn't bother me whatever you know
um so anyway we drove back
i don't know if i should tell you this
should i tell you a story all right
let's i'll tell you the story
all right so what do people do when they
go out to the desert right they always
take [ __ ] mushrooms or peyote or
whatever so i finally decided like you
know what [ __ ] this i'm gonna try it
so my buddy told me to only take like
four all right so in my head i'm like
okay that means i should take six
right because he's trying to ease me
into this thing it's like i'm only gonna
do this once
i'm never gonna do it again i wanna
[ __ ] see [ __ ] talking to me right
so i say to my wife i'm gonna take six
and she was like well why would you take
six he told you to take four so i'm like
all right you're probably right you're
probably right
all right so the kids are in bed
it's a four-hour ride it's 10 o'clock at
night i'm like [ __ ] it i'm going in
right so i take this [ __ ]
one pill makes you nervous right so i
take the [ __ ]
and uh didn't take long like 40 minutes
later it hit me
it just kind of felt like i ate like a
[ __ ] pot cookie or something and
uh i don't know
there was a couple of times like the
toilet looked like it was breathing
you know or like a painting kind of
looked like it was moving but other than
that
i wasn't like seeing [ __ ] seeing [ __ ]
right
which kind of bugged me i was like [ __ ]
i knew i should have taken
six right but the whole time i was like
nauseous i was like what is this
is this like [ __ ] heroin like you
puke or something and uh
i don't know it was like it was all
right i didn't but i didn't like
trip i just kind of got into a weirder
sort of it felt like i ate weed or
something right
i know there's all these mushroom people
going like oh man uh
dude you shoulda because everybody know
what takes muslims like oh my god dude
and like i i understand myself and i
understand
like [ __ ] the universe and i'm one
with it
and i was looking at all people and just
feeling nothing but love i i that didn't
happen for me
i think because i've been facing all of
these [ __ ] things that i've been
running from
uh it kind of went the other way like
after i was done kind of like
[ __ ] like vibrating and stuff and i was
sort of coming down
uh i was left with this profound sense
of sadness and loneliness
and i was even thinking about people
that i knew that i knew
loved me and i still was still feeling
that
and i was like what the [ __ ] is this
this is crazy right so
whatever i went to bed and then the next
morning when i woke up i kind of i think
i pieced it together
it was like it was actually a good thing
it was kind of bringing all of that
stuff to the surface
and it's part of like the whole all of
this [ __ ] that i'm [ __ ]
finally finally dealing with i also made
me realize that i kind of slept walked
through my 30s and 40s
all i was doing was trying to achieve
[ __ ]
because really that's why i got into
this business
was i'm gonna do [ __ ] that's gonna make
people laugh
and then people are gonna stop [ __ ]
with me i swear to god
it goes back to like the eight-year-old
me and then
because i thought being on stage
everybody just automatically liked you
um and also twitter didn't exist
hey you ginger [ __ ] right i thought
if i did that you know
everybody would like me people would
stop [ __ ] with me and then i also
thought like because i was afraid to
talk to
you know girls and [ __ ] when i was
younger i was like they see me on stage
and they'll come up to me i don't have
to break the ice
none of that was true you still as a
comedian i think with a musician you can
kind of force sort of brood off in the
corner
and they'd be like hey i like really
like like your ukulele you want to hang
out or something
as a [ __ ] comic you still you still
have to [ __ ]
not only do you still gotta work for it
they they want you to be funny every
eight [ __ ] seconds like what they
just saw you doing
so um yeah so then that made me start
watching stand up and everything
and then also stop paying attention in
school and just keep
fantasizing about like just crazy [ __ ]
like everything from [ __ ] being the
nude lead singer from ac dc to like
winning the medal of honor like just
[ __ ] bananas like hero fantasies
and all of it came down to me not liking
myself
and not understanding all this [ __ ]
that was
happening to me um so but along the way
because of that i
really got into stand-up comedy and then
i just wanted to be a comedian but
like when if i really get boiled down to
it
that's the reason why i did it i got
into it
um and i think all of that [ __ ]
that i then you know my 20s was figuring
out
stand up and meeting all these great
people that i have now been friends with
forever
but my 30s and 40s i just [ __ ]
you know plowed through
and and didn't deal with all of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that i
it's embarrassing like i feel like i
should have dealt with it by the time i
was like 21
22. and now i'm 52 gonna be 53.
so i think that that's what the tail end
of that little experience was
out there um
so it was a good thing as much as it
wasn't like
i think if you're so if you kind of like
yourself
i think if you like yourself
and you're at peace
with [ __ ] that's happened to you the
people in your life or
who were in your life or whatever i
think if you're at peace
or you're not even if you're not at
peace if you've just [ __ ] like
gone through sadness and allowed
yourself to feel sad
cried or whatever but as opposed to
being like i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care i don't
give a [ __ ] right if you just [ __ ] do
that
or maybe i'm just being [ __ ]
narcissistic right now and thinking that
my experience will be your experience if
you had roughly the same sort of
thing but i i would be interested to
hear what anybody who's
who's had something like that or i'll
listen to your theories
because i'm trying to figure out
i'm trying to figure out why um
all right well i think i did i don't
know it was it was
you know i did you know whatever i
[ __ ] went to joshua tree i tried to
hallucinate didn't quite happen but i
mean that's
gave it the old college try i don't know
i also think like i'm just not like
because one of my buddies is going like
what's it like right now i go well you
know the tv looks like it's growing and
it's gonna fall
sort of but not really it's not like
alice in wonderland but it
it looks like but i know it isn't
and then somebody else goes just go with
it
it's like going what i don't want to
[ __ ] think the tv's falling on me
i don't know the whole [ __ ] thing was
funny so anyway so i'm driving home and
we get stuck in this traffic
right and um
my my wife was going like where are all
these people coming from
you know i saw a couple of amazon trucks
i saw i was like well look some of these
people live out here
some of these are truckers and then if
you look around we saw all these [ __ ]
rvs and all of this [ __ ] you know the
uh all the desert people with the cool
trucks and the dirt bikes
and all of that type of stuff and um
i gotta tell you man there's some people
out there that have spent some
[ __ ] money
on this [ __ ] it's funny because you look
at them
like you look at some of these big rvs
these things are not [ __ ] cheap
it's like a [ __ ] house you know as
far as like how much it costs like
in like the middle of nowhere oh which
by the way we were looking at those tiny
little houses again
you know the little house on the prairie
that the these [ __ ] [ __ ] they
they got this little house
like the floor was particle board like
you'd get splinters in your feet if you
walked across it
it was on wheels there was a trailer
hitch they just
backed it onto this little piece of land
they wanted 75 grand
for it it's like
you know what that's kind of if you got
a big enough piece of land
i kind of get it or it's like all right
i'll buy this [ __ ] house you know
unless you're just like
uh
unless you just like truly
like a minimalist you know
and i'm i'm wondering if can you be a
minimalist
and just be that and enjoy it
and not have to tell other people about
it you know but when you do get excited
about something
right i actually i do get it i do get it
because sometimes i look around all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] i have um
that i don't even need like throw
pillows that's my number one [ __ ]
thing nobody needs to throw a pillow
i guess it makes the couch look a little
better but you can't you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i just hit another three are we gonna
lose again
some guy in the [ __ ]
wizards has like 44 points
i hope this is like if this is all
because marcus smart is out like
they need to pay that guy more money
because the second he went out we
couldn't win all right there we go
kembe walker um
anyway um
yeah as we were driving back i saw this
storage shed thing where it said
storage shed the solution to your
problems
and i was saying like the solution to
your problem is a [ __ ] yard sale now
look i get it if you're going through a
divorce you just or you just lost your
job and you want to hang on to your [ __ ]
until you can get something else
but if you just have so much [ __ ] that
you can't even um
that's not a [ __ ] foul sorry
everybody's not watching the game
that's not a shooting foul
come on oh i guess they didn't give it
to him
they didn't give it to him oh jesus
christ anyway
plowing ahead here so um
yeah like if you're not like between
[ __ ] if you just you if you got
so much [ __ ] [ __ ] you need another
structure to house your [ __ ]
i mean it's yeah you got to get rid of
some [ __ ] i i do understand that so then
this woman looked at a few other
this thing like this [ __ ] house that
she looked at was 150 square feet
all right like you walked up these
little stairs up to the bed and there
was like a rope
that you held on to instead of a
banister they couldn't even give you a
[ __ ]
banister they gave you a rope my buddy
was going yeah that's so you can hang
yourself in there
um pulled himself up now i i thought the
bed part was cool
the bed part was definitely [ __ ] cool
um but like
i don't know
i don't know what to tell you like i got
to tell you my my room
above my garage here right like i could
if i didn't have a family i could
[ __ ] live here i could actually live
here with my family i could i could we
could
if we had a kitchen in here i could
actually do that um i don't need that
much space but at some point you you
need more than 150 [ __ ] square feet i
would think in caveman days those
[ __ ] had a cave bigger than
150 feet i mean they're not gonna live
in a hole in a wall
right um
anyway so eventually she ended up
finding she found one that was even
was like bigger and it was like less
money it had to have been a ton of land
but i was saying if you bought like one
of those little ass
houses then you work your [ __ ] ass
off eventually
you could like just have somebody drive
that little house away and then build
like a
like a little bigger house right i get
it you don't want to own a bunch of [ __ ]
i don't know i
i i'm i think it's kind of cool there's
a lot of options there
although 150 square feet you're going to
live with somebody else a man and a
woman
i i i'm gonna say even back in caveman
days needed a bigger
cave than that if they were gonna well
you could drag her around by her hair
yeah guys had a little more power back
then
all right i'm gonna shut up here let's
do a little let's read a little
advertising here
um okay good only two wreaths beautiful
oh look who it is it's simply
safe everyone isn't that what we all
want to feel like
simple not a thought in your head yet
feeling safe um
anyway you know when i was simply safe
back in the day when my parents would
take me to mcdonald's and i just sit
there eating a cheeseburger that i
didn't pay for remember that when you
were just a kid you just said you had no
[ __ ] money
you just what you were broke your
pockets were empty
you know maybe there was a yo-yo way
back in the day the 70s
can you do shoot the moon um
you just go out you just get food you'd
sit there eating a cheeseburger french
fries not a [ __ ] thought in your head
look at the [ __ ] goddamn wizards
running around like they just won the
goddamn nba title
um looks like we're gonna lose another
one here
all right how the [ __ ] did oh simply
safe this is what i'm talking about
jesus built you got add you don't need
the tv on in the background
all right if you have 30 free minutes
you never have to worry about a break-in
at home
ever that is how quick and easy it is to
set up a security system from simply
safe
it's the kind of thing that is so easy
to do
you can do it during a netflix binge
watching the game
or listening to a certain podcast dude
netflix binge watch you could [ __ ]
put an addition on
you know when you really get into a show
and all of a sudden it's four in the
morning yeah i'm gonna watch one more
uh simply safe is incredible incredibly
easy to customize for your home just go
to simplysafe.comburr
you can easily choose the exact senses
you need
or get help from one of their experts
it'll get to your house in about a week
which means by the time
next week by this time next week you and
your whole family can go to bed knowing
your home is being guarded
it's easy to assume everyone in your
house already feels safe
but they might not and it's worthwhile
to talk about it
and simply safe is a small easy step to
make sure
everyone feels safe at home go to simply
safe that's the first step
the first step is you go to simply safe
the second step
is you get a weapon
it's easy to assume everyone in your
house already feels safe where am i
uh but they might not it's worth talking
about and simply safe is a small easy
step
to make sure everyone feels safe at home
yeah all you guys gun nuts out there i
got a [ __ ] goddamn over under
underneath my [ __ ] door i got a
[ __ ] uh german luger
taped to the bottom of my car table i
got a [ __ ] ar-15
and an ar-16 on either side of the door
jam
but do you can you see the guy coming up
the walk
you got to have the heads up you gotta
have the tony montana [ __ ] security
system
you wanna [ __ ] with me you [ __ ] with
the best get some
uh go to simply safe.com bird today to
customize your system and get a free
security camera
you also get a 60-day risk-free trial so
there's nothing to lose that's
simplysafe.com
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
all right uh biome
pronounced vaio like steve vi and ome
home
vio biome helps you take control of your
health
so you can improve your energy gut
health and boost your immune system
health biomes award-winning at-home
tests
decode your cellul test decode your
cellular
i think they meant your cell phone
cellular my toe
that was microchondria no wonder i
flunked that class
and microbiome health
giving you powerful insights with over
health scores fiom gives you a
precise whole food nutrition nutrition
plan can i get a new [ __ ] brain with
this thing
and precision supplements based on your
unique biological needs
eliminate the guesswork should i eat
cornflakes
should i not optimize your health and
get more energy
heavy healthy healthy weight improved
gut health better sleep and much more
viome will tell you how specific foods
affect you you may
be i'm [ __ ] gonna do this i keep
forgetting the [ __ ] [ __ ] in a goddamn
envelope and mail it to these people
you may be eating too much or not enough
of what your body needs biomes food
phone application lets you get these
answers on demand
questions about a food just check the
app biomes partners include
the mayo clinic gsk and others and is
used by olympic
gold medalists and elite professional
athletes they're all [ __ ] shredded
okay except for offensive lineman go to
v viom.com and learn
how you can get on the guy who throws
the shot put um
and learn how you can get your unique
insights for better health and wellness
use the promo code burr burr at checkout
to save ten dollars on your first
first purchase and 55 percent off all
subscription products that's vyom.com
promo code v-i-o-m-e
vyom.com promo code bird b-u-r-r
all right there you go uh bruins beat
the
rangers split this weekend lost six to
two on friday
won four to one last night charlie coyle
had a pair
i'll tell you who else uh charlie mcavoy
has been [ __ ]
finding the back of the net lately
[ __ ] blasted them in from the blue
line um
it's been a nice [ __ ] thing wait a
second wait a minute it's 110 109. my
[ __ ] eyes i thought it said there was
only 30 something seconds left
i can't read this far away was that 12
seconds left do we have the ball
do we have the ball oh [ __ ] did we just
oh god he went down hard
he [ __ ] landed on his dick um
that's a personal file when you make a
guy land on his own dick
um hanging down
sending your balls going east and west
it's a tough thing
all right let's let's do some reads here
everybody uh not some reads
some letters from you guys from you
wonderful wonderful people who listen to
this podcast god bless you
um jason tatum for two
on the replay there sorry all right
helicopters are for [ __ ] now wait a
minute
dear dearest bilum billiard brain
just writing to say how much a [ __ ] you
need to be
to fly a helicopter oh this guy's trying
to get my goat
and you know what i always take the
[ __ ] bait so good on him
uh why don't you crash like a real man
when your engine goes out instead of
floating towards the ground like the
fairy you are
i'm sure you fly helicopters because
when you grip the cyclic
control it's the only time you have
something with some power between your
legs
it takes no skill to fly a helicopter
and i'm sure my first flight would be
smoother than your shiny head
jesus christ that was nothing but net i
loved every second of that all right
jokes aside
as an anp mechanic what is a and p
you work at a [ __ ] grocery store a
and p
uh aircraft and uh what else what is an
amp mechanic
well you speak in the [ __ ] jardin
like jargon like i know who you
okay a ah where's the ann's [ __ ]
signal here
a and p
yeah grocery store mechanic
i guess i had to write what is what is
an
anp i know a person works on planes and
helicopters
in aircraft maintenance technician
refers to an individual who holds an
airflow frame
and or power plant oh airframe and power
plant
mechanic well aren't you a [ __ ]
badass
jesus christ you know those guys down
midas muffler they don't give a [ __ ] if
that weld fails you're just gonna drag
the [ __ ]
exhaust pipe down the street they don't
get nobody's gonna die
you know you're gonna give some people
some a show with the sparks but this
takes balls to do that huh
at what point do they feel you like good
enough do they make you work on little
[ __ ] uh
what do they call drones you know they
have you put those [ __ ] things
together and then they put a little rat
or a [ __ ] rabbit on it if you don't
kill the rodent
eventually you can work your way up to
people
um what by the way any anp mechanics out
there what is the rigorous testing
or do i not want to know all right jokes
aside as an a
p mechanic i love it when you talk
aviation please keep it up even if it's
about
those mind-numbing faa tests that i know
all too well
uh wish wish you the best just kidding
[ __ ] you
the pats and the celtics [ __ ] you the
pats and the celtics jesus sincerely
a self-loathing atlanta sports fan um
all right well i'm glad you enjoy that i
i
i'm not gonna lie to you my whole time
driving back
i was like picking out airports
trying to figure out where they were um
from the highway and all of that type of
stuff i was trying to find bracket i
actually looked the other way it's weird
i forgot that i always fly along the 210
and come in usually
and i was on the 10 and i looked to the
left headed west i should have looked to
the right
i wouldn't have been able to see it but
it's just i don't know
it's just another perspective probably
helped me out at some point ah
god damn it oh wait wait what what the
[ __ ] happened
holy [ __ ]
what happened god knows on that i won't
be able to [ __ ] rewind this thing
i'm sorry people watching this game is
like burr's gonna [ __ ] flip out and i
didn't
how the [ __ ] did it become 110 111 111
110.
did we go to the line did we hit a
three-pointer
who was it who was it all right i'm
rewinding i'm rewinding
oh was that when tatum drove in
he goes in again again
i saw him play at duke
you look at that splits the [ __ ]
defenders goes right in
oh my god that guy is almost as good as
i was back in the day on a nerf hoop
that's what these [ __ ] nba guys do
they they do [ __ ] on like a real thing
you know you can't even do it on a
[ __ ] nerf hoop
celtics win beautiful i love it sorry
guys i i
at some point i had to [ __ ] focus on
the podcast because most of the people
listen to
could give a [ __ ] about all of this
crap that i'm talking about um
all right yeah you know what's my dream
is
someday to fly like one of those md 600s
or whatever
uh which are basically you know
they used to kobe called the hughes 500
i think that's what what tc or somebody
had on magnum pi whatever that
character's name was
and uh i always just thought it was a
coolest looking [ __ ] helicopter
and um since then they were bought as
all corporations get bought out by
mcdonald douglas or whatever the [ __ ]
they are so now it's the md
600 they got the one with the notar
system and all of that [ __ ] but
recently a buddy of mine knows a guy who
knows a guy that just got one
and he's trying to see if uh eventually
you know i could [ __ ] go up with him
and fly it that would be
incredible [ __ ] incredible i heard
it's
like i got a buddy of mine one of the
guys that trained me
uh he flies one every day
um i forget what state he's in now but
he was saying it's almost like cheating
it's so stable how easy it is to hover
so
i'm dying to see what that's like all
right my dad is
oh my dad is an actor is an actor you
gave a shout out to get out of here
okay hey bill recently i went down a
youtube rabbit hole
which led me to watching actors talk
about
their most iconic roles while watching
tim
roth talk about his role in reservoir
dogs i noticed they show a clip
of the scene that my dad acted in
wait a minute dude is he is he the the
cop
i said buddy i am going to shoot you
in the face you don't put your [ __ ]
hands down
uh having never searched for that scene
on youtube before i was curious to watch
it again
and read what people thought of it it
was cool to see that a lot of people
thought my dad was funny and played a
realistic cop dude that guy was [ __ ]
great
he was [ __ ] great um i also noticed
that most of the comments stated that
bill burr brought them here
after finding out what they were
referring to i listened to the podcast
uh from a few years ago where you gave
my dad
rich turner but shout out to rich turner
crushing that scene
a shout out for his role in his line
buddy i'm gonna shoot you in the face
if you don't put your hands on that
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] dashes buddy
i'm gonna try to i'm gonna try to do it
justice i said buddy
i am gonna shoot you in the face
if you don't put your hands on that
[ __ ] dash
i shared that part of the podcast with
my dad
and his response was who the hell is
bill burr oh that's great
um the only tv he watches is old
westerns like gunsmoke
i relate to that guy uh i said he's a
comedian [ __ ] hilarious
he said that he had never heard of you
but
uh we're automatically his new favorite
comedian that was about a week ago
since then uh he has watched a few of
your netflix specials
and thinks you're great just thought i'd
share that too that's so [ __ ] cool
shout out to rich turner crushing that
scene
what i loved about that was i was i was
picturing the audition
uh for those of you who aren't in the
acting game
it's just words it just says buddy i'm
gonna shoot you in the face if you don't
put your hands on that [ __ ] dash
like a lot of people probably ready that
so i said buddy i'm gonna shoot you in
the [ __ ] face
you don't put your hands in the [ __ ]
desk just yell through the whole thing
the way that he did that and like
i don't know why it's like i've i've met
that cop before
it was a still the cadence of it was
like
a specific cop
you know i'd been to enough parties that
had been broken up by
cops and [ __ ] went to enough sporting
events and watched cops have to drag
[ __ ] drunks like me back in the day
out of the game
and there was a certain i don't know
there's something about that cadence
where he was doing a real guy that's
what i loved about it
um and to have a role
that size in in a movie that big
and still stand out um
like i mean that's that's i mean that's
what that's what the [ __ ] it's all about
incredible actor tip of the cap all
right
full of [ __ ] media uh
hey billy bleach boy i've been reading
threads of tweets going around from a
year ago
before the lockdown started it shows how
conservatives were concerned
about the numbers of possible deaths
some even noted
hospital crowding the liberal media was
saying it will pass
right through and everyone will be okay
oh god
guys we got to stop doing this can we
just admit we're all in the same [ __ ]
thing
i imagine there was liberals saying that
i imagine there was conservatives saying
that i imagine there was liberals and
conservatives
saying no this is a real thing
to just keep [ __ ] pointing across the
aisle we're just going to be yelling at
each other
oh god i feel like this country is in
divorce court and the judge is never
going to make a [ __ ] decision
just [ __ ] pointing at each other
anyway when lockdown started the script
was
flipped it was so easy for the media to
make
red state people anti-masculine and
liberals
uh pro shutdown all right you lost me
there was so easy for me to make red
state people
anti-mass oh and liberals pro shutdown
everyone is so gullible yeah including
you
why did the narrative change when the
lockdown started oh oh
god uh tell me their internet internet
scientist
the common sense is to keep [ __ ] open
and and to enforce masks in stores
no argument against this solution has
ever made sense wait
everyone is so gullible oh except you
you're the smart one well you know what
i'll be open-minded you explained it you
you figured it out all right
all right why did the narrative change
when the lockdown started
i followed you up to there the common
sense answer is to keep
[ __ ] open and to enforce
masks in stores
well if the narrative changed then
liberals would have been saying
that it was going to be a big deal
so why would they say keep [ __ ] open
well i thought liberals were saying
shut [ __ ] down i don't know dude
anyway no argument against this solution
has ever has ever
made sense to me maybe it's i'm sick of
seeing
fellow brown people i'm half black half
persian because i'm sure you're
wondering i actually wasn't
um maybe it's so sick of being fellow
brown people doing delivery jobs and
working grocery stores while my
white college friends can simply work
from home
it's so [ __ ] up i live in a nice
looking low-income neighborhood outside
of a major city
and it looks visibly worse since this
all started
and i don't care if people
[ __ ] that up my cousin shot shut down
after the city
said they needed to be stricter because
people weren't wearing mess
that [ __ ] wasn't my cousin's fault no
one [ __ ] around
in there at all but he had to shut down
uh so if we're into punishing people
because others can't be smart
then we're punishing innocent people
you talk about this [ __ ] all the time
yeah but also you're talking about
you're literally
trying to herd cats here and in the
united states you're trying to herd
you know upwards of half a billion
people all of whom
are on the internet all of whom think
they have the right answer
and i always go to if you can tell me if
an egg is good for you or bad for you
then you have conquered the [ __ ]
internet because
there is or if red meat's good or bad
for you
or if if that [ __ ] impossible burger
is actually a good thing or a bad thing
if you can sift through all of that [ __ ]
and [ __ ] is i how do you how do you do
it it's my question
um and yeah if you're if your cousin was
did you say it was your cousin or your
brother
uh your cousin if he was doing the right
thing he absolutely got punished
because of these [ __ ] idiots but like
the blame for it falls on all of us blue
tie
red tie media government and regular
people
all right it falls on all of us because
we're all human so everybody's trying to
do what they think is the right thing to
[ __ ] do i just do know in the end
it's it's
to sit there and like um
say that this thing is [ __ ] up because
of this political group or this thing or
that thing
is just it's not i don't agree with that
i'll put it that way i don't agree with
that
okay but people who walk around and
don't wear masks are [ __ ] morons
and not because i say say so because
i've talked to doctors and nurses
you know i went in i got my heart
checked out it's [ __ ]
cedar's one of the best [ __ ]
hospitals and they were all beside
themselves going i don't know what
people are doing i i just if they just
wear [ __ ] masks they'd be fine
um but instead i'm supposed to listen to
an expert who doesn't work at cedars
but has a youtube channel i don't know
um anyway they have no connection
to the problems they're screaming
solutions for
um and i'm not saying everybody who's
like [ __ ] the other way is not
necessarily a doctor but like
there's also you know the same way
there's bad comedians there's also
bad doctors but you don't get that gig
if you're a [ __ ] up and you're
a lunatic who has a medical degree yeah
i don't i want to hear something from a
mainstream
i don't want to talk about it just i'm
sick of it i'm [ __ ] sick of it but
i'm going to read the rest of this here
uh they have no connection to the
problems they're screaming solutions for
my neighborhood doesn't need to be told
what to do
by governor [ __ ] gavin
uh he nor anyone else i've heard behind
a podium address
any of the real issues going on they are
addressing real issues people are dying
they just don't have the solutions
okay and he is a convenient guy to [ __ ]
on
because he's the governor okay and he
has [ __ ] up from what i've heard i
don't know
but like to turn the blind eye to all
these selfish [ __ ] concerts oh my god
can't we
he's such a pain i [ __ ] hate them you
know
it's it's also that it isn't just
governor [ __ ] face gavin it's also
some [ __ ] head like that fat [ __ ] the
other week
just walking down the middle of the
street who was totally fine that if i
didn't move
he wasn't gonna move and then i'm
[ __ ] breathing whatever the [ __ ] is
inside of him and he doesn't give a [ __ ]
the same way he doesn't give a [ __ ] if
anybody in the house he lives in
gets the last sleeve of cookies because
he's obviously eating them anyways my
original post
point bill is no one has an original
point
uh this isn't done out of care or
principles it's done
out of inhumane group think
love you in the podcast love you and
thanks for the podcast all right you
kind of lost this isn't done out of care
or principles it's done out of inhumane
group think
group thinking you mean um
well i mean i i also think you know we
haven't faced anything like this in my
entire [ __ ] life
and how [ __ ] works is
they wait to [ __ ] happens
you know if you look at [ __ ] 911 and
all of that [ __ ] they waited until it
happened
until they got the level of security
that they needed to prevent something
like that from happening
because money is not spent
to prevent [ __ ] money is spent to solve
[ __ ]
they don't want to [ __ ] do all that
that's why they'll [ __ ]
they'll let design flaws be out there
and they just wait until people die
and then they fix it because
i don't know the slaves to money i have
no idea it's all out it's all above my
pay grade but i respect your opinions
and i hope your cousin's shop opens
again soon and i hope
uh governor [ __ ] gets a little more
informed and i think the average
[ __ ] idiot walking around out there
with no medical degree
you know who seeks out crazy [ __ ]
people that agree with their opinion
so they can feel justified with being a
selfish [ __ ] [ __ ] wake up at some
point but i don't think they're going to
so um so here we sit all right opinion
hospital photos of newborn and family
hey father freckles just wanted to start
out by saying thank you for your
commentary about being a father
i became a dad a little more than a year
ago and your insight helps me remember
to enjoy the little moments
and be a better father oh yeah if you
saw the excitement on my daughter's face
when she learned how to whistle oh
you know last week she got the balance
bike thing down
um it's amazing and it gives them
confidence
and you just tell them how proud you are
of them and then they want to learn
more stuff and they go into it more
confidently
it's awesome anyway he says anyway i
have been thinking about the experience
of my wife the experience my wife and i
had in the hospital after our daughter
was born
thankfully pre-covert i got to tell you
i had a kid during covid and
it was never safer because they they
pregnant women
had their own entrance um
with their first kid you know anybody
could come [ __ ] walking through the
door
so it's actually it's not as bad um
okay we were in our room when this young
lady who works for the hospital comes in
walking in with the camera saying it's
time for us to take some family pictures
when we asked about what happens with
the pictures she said
we would have the option of purchasing
digital photos
and or hard copies oh dude i would have
been like no don't
take my [ __ ] picture get out of here
uh so after taking the picture she
stepped away for a couple minutes my
wife and i talked about and decided not
to spend the money because we took quite
a few pictures on our phones and thought
that it would be enough but when the
lady came back
she showed us the photos in a slideshow
on a laptop with some twinkling ass
piano music behind it
my wife and i completely fell for it
just bawling at the cuteness and we
ended up paying
the 100 plus for the 12 digital file now
the hospital's got a new hustle
uh on one hand it seemed like this
service is a nice way
for flustered new parents to get some
nice photos to remember the day
but it bothers me that it also feels
like this lady played that slideshow
only to make us vulnerable
so we'd be easily coaxed into buying
dude that is [ __ ] hilarious
i swear to god in another life i would
get into the corporate world just
because
i want to be in i just want to be in one
of those meetings
like how does that go down
how can we squeeze another hundred
dollars out of these people
well what if what if we uh
we you know i the other the other day i
went to uh a water park
and they had this thing where you could
take pictures out well they took
pictures of you on the ride and then
afterwards you could purchase them and a
lot of people approach
i like that idea where you going with
this well you know we can take pictures
of them in the uh the hospital room you
know
when they when they're in the room and
and uh
and then what show them on the camera
well
yeah i mean that's susan what do you say
what have we played that piano music
i don't know um prank gone wrong
prank gone wrong hey you guys you want
to just
forget the whole [ __ ] mask [ __ ] i'm
sick of talking about it and i'm not
making any of you who don't want to wear
them wear them so what why don't we just
stop
let's just be friends again can we do
that all right prank gone wrong
you know what i'm not doing anything i'm
not [ __ ] talking about that [ __ ] i
will make fun of people but i'm not i'm
not gonna get
involved in this [ __ ] anymore all right
prank gone wrong hey billy meister
uh find myself in a little predicament
here
me and my wife work out regularly she
started
stealing my pre-workout powder and i
always
insist she buy her own because mine is
a little intense and expensive what the
[ __ ] is
pre-workout powder oh my god
i always look up this [ __ ] you guys talk
about and then i get i get ads for them
for like the next six years
pre-workout powder
oh like you drink like a drink oh
i was picturing you like you know like
those weight lifters like lebron james
you clap your hands i'm like
which [ __ ] weight is this guy putting
up um
okay i would always insist she buy our
own because mine is a little
intense and expensive
yeah jesus christ she's gonna [ __ ]
grow chest hair over there
of course she didn't buy her own and
continue stealing my pre-workout
so here is the prank i filled an empty
pre-workout container
with kool-aid and she's been taking it
for about two weeks
we have a beach trip coming up and fears
she will be
will overreact when i tell her she's
been taking sugar and rich kool-aid
how can i break the news to her so i
don't get killed
love the podcast and go [ __ ] yourself
wait how long have you been doing this
um it all depends on how
how good a sense of humor is yet this is
how you
[ __ ] up is you let her do it for a
week
of course she didn't buy her own i
filled
she's been taking it for two weeks
and you're getting ready to go to the
beach one of the places
where a woman feels the most i mean
everybody does
but you know i know women they the way
they feel it is way more intense
um so yeah dude um
you have two you have three options here
you tell her
and she gets mad
uh you don't tell her and you laugh
about it to yourself
the thing about it is is you came up
with a great
a great way to tell us she needs to
get her own workout powder
but then you just let her do it for two
[ __ ] weeks
then that's when it became weird that
you kept doing it but i gotta tell you
it's [ __ ] funny
that she's been drinking kool-aid
um but also you're kind of having her
take
ingest [ __ ] into her body that she
doesn't want to take
i know it's just kool-aid but now the
way the world is that'll be some sort of
stomach rape at some point
he drugged her with kool-aid and sugar
um what would i do here
dude why did you wait two weeks
all right this is what i would do
i wouldn't tell her i just say [ __ ] it
and uh
you don't want to keep drinking kool-aid
just say you accidentally knocked it
over
you spilled it on the floor and you had
to vacuum it up when she's not around so
now the kool-aid's gone
okay and then she'll go out and she'll
buy her own goddamn thing
and then you're done okay so this would
just be a joke
you waited too long dude you waited too
long um
i think you need to read up go buy a
book uh called
how to [ __ ] do a kool-aid prank
because you you went too far it's funny
that you did that
uh and if you just did it one day
and you just came home how'd you feel
you feel good about the workout just
laugh
uh remember i told you to buy the powder
and you didn't well
i replaced it with kool-aid this morning
you drank kool-aid
you know what she'd still be [ __ ] mad
but she wouldn't be as mad the fact that
you did it for two weeks is
it it's a little [ __ ] weird dude you
did it for you did it for quite a while
yeah i wouldn't say [ __ ] i wouldn't say
[ __ ] and i just act like i spilt it and
then what i would do is i would uh
i'd buy some replacement powder for
yourself and i would hide it
why do you have to [ __ ] hide it you
know what i mean i don't it's just you
know i don't know
i got to tell you dude you stumped me
you stumped me this there's something
you waited too [ __ ] long you had the
perfect little [ __ ] thing and you
could have laughed at her
and then when she got mad you could be
listen i told you
to get your own your own [ __ ] powder
you know you know what if you
shut up um yeah i wouldn't tell her
i wouldn't tell her but i would keep
putting my foot down that she can't use
your powder
tell her to get her own [ __ ] powder
before she has hairy tits oh that's what
that's what you should have done well
you know what just to let you know this
thing is overloaded in testosterone and
uh
let's just say you might need a [ __ ]
weed whacker to [ __ ]
you know get rid of your back hair
you know or she could just respect you
all right this is going off the rails
here okay
um brad stevens looks hilarious with the
[ __ ] mask going i'm watching the post
the post game here um all right that's
the podcast everybody god bless you
and uh go [ __ ] yourselves and i will
check in on you
on thursday go celtics go bruins go [ __ ]
yourselves